[Musique]
offert avec le film de jacques rouffio
la passante du sans-souci vous êtes pour
la première fois je crois de votre
carrière à l'origine d'une grande
aventure car ce film est une très grande
avance vous pouvez me dire comment
comment est né ce film d'abord lu le
livre ben oui il ya longtemps et il y a
deux ans j'ai téléphoné à jacques
rouffio pour lui demander qu'il avait
s'il avait lu le roman de joseph kessel
la passante du sans-souci j'ai lu et 10
10 le faisant les ensembles il a accepté
et c'est tout je n'ai pas fait le
travail de jacques rouffio et le travail
de jacques dire cela qui est un travail
énorme et très beau j'ai joué mon rôle
du tout alors vous avez dernier lehman
dans l'express qui sort demain que ce
film est plus qu'un signe d'ailleurs
danièle heymann écrit voulu vécu habité
par romy schneider je suppose que le
fait que ce film et les tournées à
berlin n'est peut-être pas étranger à
cette remarque non berlin
lisa l'un d'eux présente une honte pour
tout le monde une autre contrainte
depuis 30 ans imaginez paris ou toute
autre ville coupée en deux et puis
berlin
c'est aussi une ville qui est l'un des
souvenirs personnels pour moi revenons à
la passante du sans-souci vous êtes l
avis nerfs vous êtes un fan d'un éditeur
vous êtes séparé de votre mari qui
étaient déportés par les nazis et vous
venez en france où vous recueillez le
petit max dont le rôle d'adulte est tenu
par michel piccoli le petit max qui est
orphelin lui aussi été victime du
nazisme
à votre avis est-ce que le nazi ça veut
encore dire quelque chose dans
l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui
et à votre avis comment ce film sera
reçu la balle en allemagne et partout on
n'a qu'à regarder la télévision pour
s'en rendre compte chaque jour tous les
jours comment les faits une seraient
reçus en allemagne je ne sais pas je
l'espère bien
je n'espère beaucoup car c'est un bon
film premier verre vous avez tourné ce
film à une époque difficile de votre
existence d'une permet qu'une majoration
tout de suite je n'en parlerai pas mais
je voudrais tout de même savoir si vous
avez songé un instant à abandonner votre
métier oui j'ai pensé à ça mais je ne le
ferai pas l'élément maîtrise il met ma
vie dit en préparant cette émission vous
voulez tourner un petit peu moins pour
essayer de réussir davantage votre vie
qui est une chose difficilement
compatibles parfois avec le métier
d'actrice surtout à ce niveau je veux
beaucoup plus préoccupés de ma vie
personnelle de ma vie privée c'est vrai
pour le moins de films qu'avant et mai
pour réussir ma vie privée je ne peux
pas être si je ne suis pas dire surtout
qu'on me laisse enfin tranquille si on
sait vous savez ce que certaines
soi-disant photographes sont capables de
faire je pense le public a le droit de
le savoir
coût se déguise en infirmier pour
photographier un enfant moi qu'il ya une
certaine presse qui achètent et qui pue
du cul qui publie à la une commande et
où est la morale ou l attaque
[Musique]